what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel welcome to the
sit down today I have a special guest
Matt O'Connor Irish royalty
hey Dave thanks Paul for having me we
were the last kings of Ireland but as my
ex-wife said that's probably because we
pissed it up at the bar and then maybe
there may be truth in that story I'm
afraid yes so you um founded the
organization fathers for justice all
right you have a book You released in
2007 yeah and um the number one or goal
of your organization is to end
fatherlessness and the cancer and the
cancer of the family breakdown correct
that that's our that's number one on the
website that's number one that's our
that's our number one uh Mission
objective which has proven to be
obviously
um I thought I could change the law in
three years and I started a campaign in
2001. sadly I'm still here 21 years
later uh chipping away at the Injustice
uh and the uh appalling treatment of
fathers and and children in our secret
family calls are more in common uh with
Putin's Russia than a supposed
Progressive modern democracy
you said what law are you trying to
change well we're trying to create some
laws really because at the moment
um if you're separated dad you've got no
rights in law to see your children
which is astonishing
uh the government's position is that
they do not believe what's called a
legal presumption of contact would be
helpful and that means that your only
right is to make an application to court
to see your children some fathers get
confused because you've got parental
rights responsibilities so if your name
is on the birth certificate you'll have
those automatically but they are very
very pitiful and very limited they're
going to give you rights to educational
and medical information it does not give
you in right in law to see your children
the presumption of the courts is such
that the children live in the mother
automatically that is the Assumption of
assumption
um and that the father as I said will
need to make an application of court to
see his children and he'll need to go
for a safeguarding process
um where safeguarding checks are carried
out to be fair on both parties but the
treatment of farmers is fundamentally
discriminatory it's fundamentally in
breach of their eyes is fundamentally in
breach of the human rights of a child to
see their father to enjoy not just the
uh presence and involvement of the
father but the paternal family
Eternal family you know the grandmothers
grandfathers Aunts Uncles everybody else
who can support that child
um so it's a really difficult and
troubling system uh I say it's
completely secretive there is no
accountability no transparency we have
an unelected unaccountable Judiciary
operating in complete secrecy even Kim
Jordan would probably Flinch at the idea
it's a sub form of Justice what do you
mean by that well I just mean it's the
level of secrecy is is astonishing so I
kind of want to I want to take a step
back just because
there's a lot to take in yeah so so if I
if I was to have a child with someone
okay yeah and we
then we separate we break up he has no
legal rights to the child correct none
so if he were if you were to separate if
he's on the birth certificate he gets
the education right yeah seek his good
information about education and
information about medical oh but it's
just information no no say I I still get
to choose where the kids go to school
the child lives with you this part is
the father will leave the house
and as soon as the father leaves the
house because he thinks he's doing the
right thing this is what I call Sagal ad
syndrome so we think we're doing the
noble thing we're doing the right thing
but if the father relationship breaks
down and he thinks oh it's all good to
be living together the father will
generally be the person who leaves the
house like 40 when he does that his
rights go up in smoke like that oh Susie
leaves because when he's living together
with the mother uh there's a presumption
of share care as soon as he leaves
mother becomes the parent with carer
isn't a parent he becomes the
non-resident parent with no lawful
rights what if what if it was the other
way around would it switch or no well if
the child was living with the father
then the father would be
um effectively become the resident
parent a Mum would become the non-muslim
parent but I say that is very very rare
what percent of the time does that
happen less than one percent less than
yeah
when women we can be spiteful so if we
don't know
women are
up you know can be predatory of become
far more predatory
sexually in terms of relationships the
informality you can meet somebody a
couple of clicks online relationships
are more disposable
um well who wants inconvenience of that
in a father right you know that's what
it comes down to who what who wants the
inconvenience of having a father around
that the mother won't care for or
doesn't lie always resentful against
because maybe the father's being
unfaithful maybe he's done something
wrong maybe he's not enough money you
know far better just to airbrush the
father out and that is the reality of
our society today it's disposable and
that's why we've got over three million
kids living in fatherless homes in this
country yeah you've said one out of
three children live without a father wow
I didn't realize it was that high this
is this is a pandemic it's off the
charts and obviously what that creates
is the whole list of consequences you've
got in in this area like in in East
London you've got or feral Estates with
fellow boys you know young boys roaming
around whose only Father Figure is a
local gang leader or is the local drug
dealer
um for poor girls whose first experience
in often of a man is a sexual one
because her father hasn't been present
so this cycle of fatherlessness condemns
our children to you know anti-social
Behavior to end it actually ended up in
the very cause that separated them from
their fathers in the first place that's
the Paradox here so okay so back
to if so he leaves the house then what
what's the next thing that happens well
he'll want to see the children and then
and then oftentimes as I found out the
women will say no yeah right the women
will say no for anyone of a multiple
number of reasons but they are
unfortunately the law empowers women to
deny tax access to the kids and what
they effectively do and what the mothers
are doing
and it's appalling because this is
emotional abuse they're actually
weaponizing the children
they're turning the children to a weapon
to punish
their former partner to punish the
children's father to separate them is
the cruelest thing you could do
what's the word punishing somebody that
you hate the most is to stop them seeing
the people they love the most and that
I'm afraid and I've been doing this 21
years we've had over a million inquiries
there are tens of hours of cases
and I I can tell you from my own
personal experience of dealing with that
volume of cases that is a reality
um and it's it's it it's tragic because
a system literally encourages mother
knows to do that encourages mothers to
make false allegations so we live in an
age where
um to get legal aid for a mother to get
legal aid she has to make allegations of
domestic abuse or coercive controlling
Behavior or whatever it's going to be in
these days they're going to get what uh
coercive controlling Behavior or she can
make allegations no you said she makes
allegations why to get legal aid to get
legal aid to gain the system
so as legal is that the same thing like
benefits here yeah it's like free free
legal aid free legal so she will have a
solicitoring culture of embarrassed in
the court most fathers won't get legal
aid like the vast majority of weight so
the father it's there's no equality of
arms no quality of arms it's completely
one-sided the fathers effectively like
handcuffed with his hands tied behind
his back the mother will get legal aid
if she makes even the flimsy of
allegations literally any allegation is
taken at face value in a family cause
so this is where to some extent this is
fed through into the me too moment but
it started in the Family Justice System
was where you can now
it's a bit like a sailing Witch Hunt I
went to Sega a few years ago it's quite
interesting and looking at the history
of that but now it's the witches doing
hunting so you could just point a finger
at something and go this happened and
the courts will take it as Bible truth
so and to the fathers then the
obligations down to the father to have
to disprove an allegation and what that
comes down to does it require any
evidence it's decided and civil court on
the balance of probability I.E whose
evidence the judge prefers and let me
just finish this point
the reality is when a judge is faced
with a mother
who will often be behind a screening
court because she's always terrified of
the father
she's behind the screen and she's crying
and she's rocking her back forwards
walking batters and forwards would the
judge prefer her testimony or the
testimony of the big ugly area I'll blow
in the other corner and 9.9 times out of
ten the judge will go with the mother do
the judges ever like wise up to this and
start to think no so I'd imagine if
you're doing this 20 like if you're a
20-year judge right I would imagine that
you you it's kind of like I've been
doing this show for a year and a lot of
men's complaints when I started the show
I didn't really understand then I do the
show for a year
um
give fathers the kids
oh my God I'm like but it's like it
changed your perspective like why don't
the judges I'd imagine they'd have
there's no way they couldn't no like
have no idea that the women were lying
or some of them anyway you have to bear
in mind these are drastic judges
Jurassic Jurassic you know like that age
they're that prehistoric uh thinking
Stone Age courts they are indoctrinated
they have an indoctrination and they
believe this is the way it is
um that all men are practically violent
perpetrators so don't forget even even
it's not just the judges it's the entire
bureaucratic command structure of the
Civil Service of the ministry of Justice
um see what they've done is they've
reversed the basic tender Justice
innocent until proven guilty in the
family courts you were guilty until
proven innocent the burden of proof
should be on the court to demonstrate to
demonstrate you are a risk to your child
because they're just automatically going
to think she's telling the truth because
there's no truck there's no jury it's
just the judge
and so then he has to defend himself he
will go to often his allegations go to
What's called a fact find in here and
it's literally he said she says finding
hearing fact finding him okay and it's
literally he says she says okay so whose
testimony does the judge prefer and the
majority of the time they will go with
the mother and the mother will switch on
the Water Works she'll be crying she'll
be in distress she'll be saying how
terrible her life is
um and the reality is I'm afraid uh
quite often the complete opposite of
that
um but there is no the father these are
pharmacals like all pharmacogic because
they are institutionally discriminator
against men on the basis of like my
gender on the basis I've got a
million two veg I mean I went through it
21 years ago
and
it still upsets me you know that I went
for it to try and see my child as boys
and it's like yeah it's heartbreaking
be difficult so which is
foolishly I'm still here yeah I'm still
here because I'm a father of three boys
26 25 and and 17 and you know they've
had some issues and they're growing up
and it's a difficult age to be
um a young man or a boy really difficult
age in a current climate and and so I
feel
a duty of care to them but also I feel
strongly
um about this is this is something which
is you know from here and um somebody's
got to do something about it you know so
so I'm I'm still I was in a high court
the other day and I've been threatened
with imprisonment I'm afraid of content
to call proceedings in jail for for what
uh for publishing information about
court case
and uh the judge has said to me the
other day and I was drug fathers are
just me were dragged into the high court
on this case
and she's ordered me to stay take stuff
down off the Internet it's just a judge
in in the high court in in London why
were so I don't
I'm not like a legal yeah I don't know
are you not allowed to like make those
well no because the Court's a secret
really it's a secret but what they do
occasion they'll publish selective
judgments like either to make the father
look bad or they'll publish the excerpts
what I want and I'm insistent upon oh
guys my grave right is that
every core door is open every window is
open and they are exposed to the
disinfectant of sunlight and we have
proper accountability we have proper
transparency so we can see what is
happening behind closed doors so um I
want to go back to the so if I can be
seriously no no I mean um we're gonna go
into that I just I'm trying to because I
just want to understand the process that
happens so
I I he leaves the house then he wants to
go to court yeah then I then now we have
a court date is that what happens yeah
so maybe I got a lawyer I generation is
Germany mandatory okay but most movies
don't attend mediation it's only
mandatory field applicant not respondent
so 97 of applications are called from
fathers most mothers that makes a
mockery of idea mediation
how can you media if you don't have two
people in the room you can't so so okay
so so then it'll go to court his
application will go to court and
there'll be
uh calf gas will do what's called
safeguarding letter and they'll speak to
the mother
and speak to the father they generally
do police checks Social Services checks
etc etc
um if there's any allegations then
there's a thing called practice
Direction 12j comes in which means
there's no contact between the father
and the child until those allegations
have been determined wow
I could I could go if I didn't want him
if I was really feeling spiteful I could
go and just say make an allegation
against him but what you do is you would
go you go and speak to a solicitor just
listen to say have you experienced
domestic abuse because if you have
you're going to get free legal age you
have to pay a penny
what you get free legalized so you don't
pay a payment so they're paying women to
accuse men essentially yeah I mean like
because otherwise she would have to pay
for the lawyers
so she gets a free so this is why I
wanted to like go step by step because I
just wanted to it's hard to believe I
know it's hard to believe so okay so we
we break up yeah then I go to the first
he has to do the mediation yeah
mediation I don't show up yeah he he
shows up okay there's then they do the
background checks then they'll give a
lot of a form to say he's attended
mediation then he can make the
application to see when that application
to call Kafka the court welfare service
will then do the safeguarding letter
the safeguards the Safeguard less which
means looks the allegations but the key
point is here as soon as mum sees a
solicitor the solicit will tell her how
to game the system straight away so the
solicitor okay and is that's the same as
like a family court attorney
um yeah yeah it's from the state yeah
I'm guessing Okay yeah yeah it's not
there's there's hundreds of kind of low
life scummy solicitors who who who just
offer like Family Law Services uh and
and yeah but that's how they get they
get legal aid they get they get their
bread and butter from legal aid so legal
aid board pays the mother's fees uh
which can account into millions I'm
afraid
so of our taxpayers money so we're
paying towards a system to fund this
pandemic of false allegations so mothers
get free legal aid second deny that has
access to their kids so we're paying for
it
so now I so now I have a court date I'm
guessing right so there's a court date
how long would it take from the initial
he leaves the house to get the court
date three to six months three so here
ready so if a child's one yeah you'll
lose it he's already and and kids
develop the most in the first two years
so if she's batshit crazy he has like no
rights yeah correct wow and so so it's
gonna take like let's say it takes six
months to get the court date now it
could take between three to six months
that depends on the backlog and let me
just tell you why that is
they're digging judges at a graveyard so
not enough judges okay do enough enough
magistrates they're trying to create
magistrates the courts have a huge
backlog pre-covet there was a huge
battle and there's an even bigger battle
so it could be even longer your average
case length at the moment is over 12
months the average case length is 12
months to get a court date or that is
the case to finish but you you could be
between three to six months some cases
I've no longer the six months recently
they've gone I've gone longer to get to
it first and he has no rights to his kid
he's just out of life wow so then
then he gets
um
he gets the court date and does he know
he's being accused of domestic abuse
well of the safeguarding letter will say
that he made recommendations about so
there'll be a directions he was called
directions here and they'll decide
whether or not there's going to be any
contact between the father and the chart
but if there's no allegations per se
then kafkas will generally say oh
there'll be some contact that's going to
be generally quite Limited in the first
instance she might get you might get a
few hours on a Saturday if you're lucky
you might get an overnight
um you should get every weekend but
again depends on the age of the child
there's a lot of variables the courts
look at it and go if you're getting any
contact you should be grateful for
anything at your game well even even if
let's say he gets once a week which is
probably I would guess high like if a
guy got once a week is that yeah well
yeah it can be it it it it it it it it
just depends because it depends what the
Safeguard letter says because the
allegations issue and that's a big issue
if the allegations are taken at face
value you'll say practice Direction 12 J
count there's no content kafkas will
advise a call there should be no contact
pending a fact-fired in hearing now what
happens then is that mother will file
it's called a Scott schedule of
allegations oh what a Scottish schedule
okay which is a list of allegations
that's then serving the Father the
father has to respond if the father's
going to make any character allegations
he does that so that could be another
three months before we even get to a
fact finding so I've got a fact finding
hearings this year that are in November
November right wow November and that
means following the fact final hearing
kafkas would then do a section 7 report
which is a welfare report that's another
three to four months at least which
means the final hearing wouldn't be for
over a year and a half
so and all that time you know most of
that time he's got no contact now if the
core
makes findings against the father of any
form of abuse
he may need to attain what's called a
domestic abuse perpetrators program
right which is 52 weeks
sorry 32 weeks not 52 32 weeks long
and
I still don't know anybody who has
successfully completed that course it's
like a North Korean regi re-education
course because you've got to admit even
if you don't agree with the findings
made by the court
if the court has found that you're
abusive or you've been coercive
controlling or you've been you've pushed
somebody that's the other thing they're
expanding the definition of that's use
aren't they because I thought abuse was
getting punched in the face by a guy and
now I'm finding out that it's like he
can control you with money yeah that's
abuse yeah so if you Pearl if you want
to go off uh and selfridges
going to selfridges and spend like two
or three thousand pounds in beautiful
dresses right and he tried stopping you
that might fall under definition of
coercive control wow if the father's
worried about for example arguments
you know between him and the mother
he goes to the police the police tell
him you should record everything
record everything right if you've of
course everything I've had this the same
police force arrested the guy for
coercive controlling because he was
recording everything
as evidence so it's like you can't even
win the thing to do is don't tell
anybody you record anything I always say
to people just leave the phone in your
pocket just leave it the audio recording
and then you say you kept
contemporaneous nose uh if it goes to
court and there's an issue
the other thing men are really bad at
doing is reporting domestic abuse right
because there's a stigma and shame
attached to that so lots of dads so I
was assaulted in 2017 for example but if
you've not reported it you've not
pursued it there's nothing you can do
about it if the mother said she was
assaulted in 2017 they will leap all
over you and treat it as Bible truth
without any evidence whatsoever
and all he has to do is convince the
judge
all she has to do is convince the judge
yeah he doesn't he doesn't the
institutional discrimination is such
they take you just need to sit with the
me too as I call it the me me and me too
because it's all about me and usually
look at that moment and it's fingerpoint
it's literally justice has come down to
finger pointing and it's terrifying
because you can destroy your reputation
your career as a man these are dangerous
dangerous times to be a man I've got so
I've got three sons I say you know it
could be what do you take when you go
out of dating and we take a breathalyzer
do you take a lawyer with you with a
consent form if you're going to have sex
you know what the do you do well I
don't know I mean it's just um my son
for example his school
last year he was told to cross the right
way segregated the boys and girls out
assembly and the boys were told
basically you're toxic if you see a
woman walking up the High Street you
must cross the other side of the road
wow my son
my son
demonized in this kind of horrific way
and that is the age we live in it's a
it's a warm event
Ace of War on boys
um and there's very very little being
done to stop it because we were quite
political will it is quite political
change and at the moment there is no
political will because everybody is
terrified of women terrified of me too
movement everybody count as the
organizations like mumsnet the largest
constituency of floating voters or
single mothers and that's why politics
that's why politicians count out so
they're the largest constituency
floating voters with floating voters so
floating voter means you're you're kind
of quite um uh again you're quite
promiscuous in your voting intention
whereas men are quite tribal oh so like
they can swing more yeah like it's like
they'll vote more in their engine yeah
men are like Democrat well I don't know
what it is
a bit like football clubs yeah football
club nice sport particular political
party
so so there's all these kind of
different moving parts and the plate
tectonics are just like 100 years ago it
was it was it was a patriarchal it
wasn't patriarchal so what the
patriarchy but now
they showed your big mother it's the
matriarchy not the patriarchy
you know
um this myth that we live in an age of
male privilege where is mind about
privilege I've got no rights in my kids
I've got no representation in my car
though I've been locked out more times
when I got dinners
um uh you know I'd be treated like a
terrorist for campaigning I've been
um you know you know I've had a
terrorism Commander come down and see me
because all because you're advocating
for men's rights yeah yeah and we put
some overweight guys in Lycra on
buildings you know
and so so it's crazy that's how crazy it
is so I
so I go to court yeah
um and then at court what what happens
so basically
um the father will be unrepresented he
might have what's called a Mackenzie
friend somebody's there to help him but
they can't speak on his behalf
um luckily and why why not like do you
not have the right to an attorney here
no no you you we we would never advise
use of a solicitor in in the family
courts it would be it would be um
solicitors are definitely a significant
part of the problem okay
um are there any solicitors that like
work exclusively work exclusively for
men like we have a couple in the US
there is there is I mean apart from us
um you know I think there is one firm
out that is doing it but we
you know my view on solicitors as they
just their patreon game Keepers on One
telephone call Pearl their telemunds to
stop
dad's having access to the kids the next
telephone call offer in false the
fathers and you're going to burn on
average 10 to 30 000 pounds
because that's what a lot of the I've
had um I had a guy named Destiny I don't
even I don't know he's a streamer but he
he was saying how it's really not that
prevalent of a problem than getting
access to their kids and if men would
just see this country and man no he's
not
um but so I I don't think he was
speaking on that but
um that was one of the things that a
different attorney I spoke to
um or an attorney I spoke to said was
that because the other side will see
that and say oh well men are just not
fighting for their kids well that's
obviously clearly complete
bollocks isn't it I mean look
um evidence 21 years over a million
inquiries and I've dealt with MPS I've
dealt with Chief constables I've dealt
with celebrity chefs I've dealt with
rock stars I've dealt with
everybody really yeah so even even
nobody tell me there's no
problem because that's bother
and he he's there in denial or they're
just ignorant so there's the other two
things there that's happening there but
um
yeah this isn't just a problem here oh
it's yeah
I said I was in Barbados last year
and
you know I I would say I apologize I was
also I ended up doing some work out
there and all these dads I was in a
restaurant some people come up to me oh
thanks for coming out and helping out
and you know I'm trying to see my child
and so it's a big problem in in in the
Caribbean everywhere I go
there's a problem it's you it's a first
world problem pal it's in the states
it's in Europe it's in most First World
countries Australia have the same
institutional prejudices really it's not
unique to you know how like why is that
well I think the legal systems all tend
to copy each other very similar but I
think if you look at the bureaucratic
command structure it's what Gorbachev
called basically like the institution of
government the civil services as we call
it is that they are embedded with a
particular type of our geologically
driven person and they tend to be
feminists and they tend to be people who
have a view which is generally anti-mail
father phobic uh which says that
basically all men are a risk to their
children all men are violent wow and all
men have to be treated in this kind of
way what they're trying to do what they
have but aren't women more violent
towards their kids than men well most
majority of abuse perpetrated on
children yeah so I mean that's that so I
think that's the stars
and and of course if you look at
domestic abuse if you look at last
British crime survey which I think was
for 2019 one in three domestic abuse
victims of men
and that will be massively underreported
because the stigma and shame attached to
men reporting domestic abuse I mean so
that's another well and they don't talk
about how a lot of times the girls hit
first yeah how are you if you hit first
you're just beating each other at that
point you could argue that he's
defending himself I I would never hit a
man and then cry when he hits him back
what do you expect to happen like
is that well that would be a fairly
Common Sense approach but common sense
is does not exist in the family and so
in if so he goes to court you advise
them don't waste your money
represent yourself get good help and
advice for a fraction of the cost and
advice either from fathers or Justice or
from somebody else who other groups out
there but don't don't do the barristers
because they're because they're they're
kind of on the woman's side anyway
the solicitors David support share care
so what you're looking for your
solicitor who you're paying stupid sums
of money
will not support what you're asking for
they will not tell you it's the biggest
show I have further my casework involves
uh very expensive cases with ads are
spent you know 60 100 200k on solicitors
and they've not been told what's going
to happen to them so for example
you know we would say avoid the fact
finder here if you can avoid it
um but they need they don't tell you
what the cost implication is going to be
but on an average case minimum you're
going to spend 10 to 30. but it's more
likely to be 30. and in reality it's
going to be significantly more than that
our duty of care and that's pounds right
yeah in the US that's probably like 30
that's like 40 or yeah yeah
so our duty cares when I speak to a dad
is we tell them as it is we give them
home truths because they don't like it a
lot of time but I'd rather tell you the
truth
and I'd rather tell you what's going to
happen
and prepare you for that as you prepare
for the worst type for the best plan for
the best but you've got to know what's
coming down the line to you but if a
solicitor told you it was going to
happen to you you wouldn't give any
money at all
that's why I won't tell you what's
likely to happen so they don't have they
don't have an interest in helping you
because they're trying to make money I
mean ever I mean in a way everyone has
to make money but but there's it's
different because they're getting most
of their money from the women yeah like
so why would they why would they help
someone that's not their customer well
but they'd expect you to pay so what the
dab will do the dab will tap into a
savings for example
um if I had actually honestly the number
of cases you get
men come to me I've spent yeah all this
money on solicitors or say for example
I've got divorce a lot of good Dads get
divorced the solicitors say well yeah
Mr sand said we'll deal with a divorce
first then and um you know we'll just
get there you know deal with that and so
they get divorced do with the finances
and then the wife's sitting in the house
she's got the kids got the cash
and then she stops him and seeing her
kids
and the dad goes back hang on a minute
I've got divorce it's all sorted
oh there's a little bit we didn't tell
you about you need to get a charter
agency to see your children
and how can you get divorced if you
don't know what the division split of
time between you and the mother is for
the children because divorce is based on
need so if you're seeing the children on
the one week on one week off basis or a
50 50 then you'll need would be equal
and therefore you'd have a more
Equitable division of the Assets in a
divorce so the whole time
you know the dads are literally leaping
off the cliffs like that means because
they're believing what the solicitor
tells them and you just I'm afraid in
this one particular area of law which is
a kind of dark stagnant horrible
Backwater of the British legal system
this is the one area you would not rely
on a solicitor I say they will support
you like the Rope supports the hanging
man avoid so they avoid they avoid the
solicitors in court well they run out of
money they run out of money yeah and
then they end up doing themselves and
then so in court how what percent of the
cases do they get any custody would you
guess well we get all all track record
is about we either 70 to 80 success in
our reuniting children and fathers you
over what percent 70 to 80 oh wow 70 to
80 success rate okay so where we're
dealing with uh cases where
um we're involved with managing
we can either get contact restarted in
most cases not always we're not miracle
workers we haven't got a magic one where
I've got a silver bullet we can you know
out a problem but most cases
um that we're involved in with it where
we manage the case that's important
um yeah we we have a higher track record
and we have a hard track of traffic
we're getting share care and you and you
get men other men that come to you have
no contact with their kids no some men
have got contacts some men are looking
to increase the contacts some men you
know guy the other day I was chatting
towards chatting on a Sunday morning
actually and he had you know sat in his
hands for a few years he was getting I
think it's getting one day one night a
week and he lived in proximity said
maybe should have been having share care
but what would happen is the children
got older his daughter was 16. and she
stopped coming she stopped seeing him
and she's too old now because the court
won't make an order for a child over the
age of 16. so he left it trying to
thinking that you know he could reason
with the mother that things would
improve and unfortunately the direction
of travel is the longer you leave it the
worse it simply gets you can only reason
with reasonable people that's why I say
and most mothers let me tell you are not
going to be reasonable right for the
reasons I've stated and the more
desperate you are the more you beg to
see your children the more that empowers
the mother the mother will feed off it
feed off it she'll feed off your
desperation and that's why I say that in
some cases you've got no contact you
have a choice but to go to court but
we're also very keen on dads enforcing
their parental rights responsibilities
because a lot of dads don't and the
other thing we often do is we do like
gdpr requests which is a data protection
request to schools or subjects requests
local authority to get information about
their children because a lot of dads
will only get see the top 10 of the
iceberg they won't see the other nine
percent of what's going on with their
kids beneath the water line so there's a
lot of things that we advise a lot of
protocols we follow what percent of your
cases can you get 50 50 custody in and
what would you say uh just in the
general court I think it's about only
ten percent okay yeah I mean ours ours
is probably 20 25. wow so even like
being we can't get it but it's a
struggle and I'm going to be honest with
you it's sometimes a struggle because of
the dance
the dads could sometimes be a problem
um and I've got to be on I had a case
last year where the dad was yeah wanted
to wanted to attack the mother
and was like and we're going you can't
do you just can't do this right the best
thing we can do
is forget yeah if you've got anger with
them against the mother hey nobody
understands that movie
but you've got a pocket at one side this
is not the environment to be going off
if you think that something's unjust as
that you know it will fit you out for a
Superman outfit and put you on
Batman and Palace right but you don't
risk your contact with your child in
this case we said
let's gain the call we've got a great
opportunity here to get a one week on
one week off order we went into court
I threatened to string them up by his
testicles outside on a Lamppost
we didn't follow the instructions in a
nicest possible way I said if you follow
our instructions we're confident
he followed the instructions great guy
he followed the instructions going to
court mothers Barrister who didn't know
the case at all
the judge said because we drafted up
what's called a consent order so we'd
ran all the order out for the judge
saying 50 50 and they're just going this
is amazing this is a really good order I
think this is really good so he said I
said what do you think of well it's a
very good order
slam down walked out 50 50. share care
live with my parents order
Victory that's what we want but that
should be the standard that we have to
work so hard so hard to get those cases
overnight so it's like
if so if if a guy makes a kid or has a
kid with a crazy lady right there's a
lot there's a lot of that going on yeah
I know there's a lot of that going on I
know
so essentially if he wants to see his
kid he I just want to make sure I
understand it so he he first
um he he shouldn't leave the house but
after he usually does stay in the
property stay in the property and what
you should do if he's in the house is
you should draft What's called the
living together arrangements so you work
out uh you know you give undertakings
not to make allegations against the
other person you agree a rotor for use
of the rooms the bathroom the kitchen
spending time with the children
and you agree that you know between you
or you get solicitor to ratify us at one
point you might use the solicitor for is
because if you're still in the property
to agree living together arrangement
while you're still in the property you
apply for a live with both parents order
right and that's important you do it
while you're still living with the
children and you make that application
so you do those two things
and that means if you are removed from
the property you leave the property at
least if you've got an order in place
then that's going to protect your
relationship with your children what
tends to happen Pearl is this if you're
living together and I want to get rid of
you she will call the police
make an allegation that you pushed her
no police will come and arrest you and
then bail you not to return to the
property
that's one more game with you the other
way is when you're out
they change the locks and it gets less
on board and they get what's called a
a non-monal station order and they're
giving out like confetti and she says
I've suffered years of abuse and harm
and he's terrible he's done this doesn't
again no no evidence required just say
and the court will give her a
non-monestation order for the farmer not
to contact the Marvel approach the book
given 100 100 yards or whatever
so again another way of removing the
father from the home really easy this is
really straight this happens every day
um I still change the locks to change
the locks which is unlawful because if
you use your home but nobody gives a
um so the father's easily removed from
the property so if you're in the
property we say avoid all arguments
avoidable disputes get a living together
Arrangement work it out like that and
get your application in straight away
for um Olivia by parents order what then
tends to happen if you get your
non-molestation order a lot of dads get
not the sad about it I want to defend
their reperto forget it because they're
not molestation order in 99.9 cases will
remain in place because that's the
courts presumption but what you've got
to bear in mind with a normal station
order maximum five years inside for a
breach
five years in sight so yeah bridge for
breach for con if you contact the mother
or use a third party the contact number
you risk fine five years of jail five
years of jail
you have to go for this list there but
what you don't want to do is a guy he
can't answer these stories because I've
got yeah millions of them upstairs
um there's another guy I think it's a
couple of years ago
um we said don't speak to the mother the
mother was contacting him even there was
a normal station order he's saying she
keeps contacting me Matt she's she keeps
contacting me I said do not respond it's
a trap it's a trap
it's a trap it's a trap so I said so was
he there
you can't she invites him around for a
Chinese Takeaway
sounds great
he gets in there and he's chowing down
on his first sweetness out of bought
ball it's great it's just a
feast
knock at the door
coming
he said can I just finish my meal no
he's like shoves a couple of Poor Paws
in his jacket pocket to take with him
he's cuffed
that's it they've got power arrested
I had a case of a mother
who said the father had contacted her
and was in breach of the normal and he
was arrested spent a day in prison
but that was a old non-monastation or
she showed the police there was a new
normal station order allowing him to
contact the mama and she delivered a
non-molesterion order that's that's
exactly what it sounds like yeah you're
not allowed to contact a mother but she
used an old one to get him arrested when
in reality there was a new one which she
hadn't shown the police which said he
wasn't allowed to contact her because
she had no solicitor so again I had a
case of uh it's another rape so we get a
lot of what we're called fake rape cases
I had a mother a ledge again simply to
destroy the father destroy his
reputation and to die of access to his
son the mother alleged that she was
raped in 2014.
and she kept a diary
written diary about these kind of sexual
assaults and stuff and his rapists that
and then when the because your criminal
proceedings can be disclosed the family
proceedings when when there was
visibility of this of of his diary
there were some entry marks of like sort
of 2018.
I thought this is a bit odd why would
you write 2018 if the diary was written
in 2014.
this is raised with the police the
police investigated
I found out the diary was produced
in Hong Kong in 2016.
two years after she said she wrote it
so it's a complete fabrication
and she was arrested for providing a
course of Justice
she wisely gave a no comment interview
with us Alyssa present and sadly there
was no prosecution
but that will give you some extent this
flavor
for some of the desperate tactics that
we say and there's no consequences
there's none and they're actually
incentivized to do it because they get
the free legal aid correct if they
accuse him of something correct and
there's no consequence if they lock him
out of the house there's no consequence
for tricking him into getting arrested
like they can just get away with this
and go to court and still get access
probably get
ninety percent of the time they're going
to get access to their kids unless they
go against you well well I mean the
mother will get you know you know say
yeah 97 so it's it's
the entire system is completely rigged
you said 97
97 you know 97 by vast majority The
Residency is given to mothers I mean and
I'd say we are successful again share
care but that is they are rare the
course don't like equality they don't
like this idea that the men should be
equal
but
I said well I was in pop holders last
year
and I did this interview with with a guy
there and he was like it was really you
know quite he wasn't a friendly brother
to his other fathers I can tell you he
was really sexy it's quite a quiet
demonizing dads as deadbeats and
feckless fail fathers
um it's a really common narrative I
heard it all the time growing up born in
Vegas do you know who coined the phrase
debit dad's born away wow in the 80s
that's where this comes from
and then what every say the power
institution is every country have gone
great let's use dads as whipping boys
yeah we're cheap political Capital so we
go create the idea of feckless fail
fathers of all deadbeats who don't want
to see their kids don't want to pay
money the reality is right the vast
majority in my opinion are desperate to
see their case the vast majority of dads
want 50 50 shared care we demand
equality parental quality and yet we
live in an age where my country I am
reduced to the status of a sperm bank
I'll reduce the status of a cash
point
you know really
how how could you do that to half the
population how could you demonize and
toxify
you know and make us reduce to this
pitiful status and then pretend we live
in a patriarchy it is beyond
belief and that's before we ever get
onto the
fraud or the Rings marriage you know and
that's another institution which is
truly appalling why is why is it like
this like it
it hasn't always been like this has it I
think you've just got as I say my only
and I've dealt with civil servants in
Whitehall
and there is this ideology I was in the
high court overdose judge I was in high
court with the Barrister I was in the
high court with the children's Guardian
in this case and they are all
all consumed by this ideology
this fanatical feminist ideology which
basically means that all men are risked
oh where where does it come from because
I'm just thinking like if
if you're going to have a hundred people
in an organization right or in a certain
position right I would think like people
come from different backgrounds like
where did that ideology come from well I
do you know that's a really good
question and I can't answer that
emphatically because
there's so no research yeah I mean you
know we're just a guy scraping around
the surface trying to trying to work out
what's going on but
as I say politically this requires a
political solution but none of the
political parties will touch touch
anything to do because because of the
floating exploding voters and that
encourages so if you fought the
conservative party was the party of the
family think again we are all consumed
with minority rights in this country
minority rights the only group that
doesn't affect minority
a white man black men men generally do
not fit the minority box so we have
rights we had the cultural victimhood
for women
for girls which is fine
um
but you wouldn't if you if you would
treat him if I was you know Muslim
you know and you're treating me like I'm
not sure you get away with it I'm not
sure if I was anyone of a number of
minorities you'd get away with treating
fathers you know in this particular way
were treated like dogs in fact dogs have
probably got more legislation protecting
their rights than there are protecting
eyes we're left for dead at the side of
our road that's how we treat the fathers
father suicides like the death rate
separated dads is three times higher
than mothers
if you look at separated dads who move
out 70 of them live in poverty they have
issues with trying to get housing shared
accommodation of shared accommodation
you won't be having kids around today
bed sets you know either dear friend of
mine died recently and and could one
Davis
and here he lived in a bed set and I
remember sitting there with him drinking
whiskey one night and literally you
couldn't swing a hamster in this
room
and he was just on the corner of the bed
I was in a chair
the worst night of my life just so
depressing
you know and and that's what we have
been reduced to
I'm lucky I'm fortunate I see my three
boys
I'm lucky you know it takes us totally
mentally because you're dealing with you
know we're dealing with three or four
suicides a month and you're having to
deal with speak to people's parents
you know I had a guy I can't say too
much about it had a guy who who his
parents contacted me and they said
they've lost their son
and they've lost their grandchildren
and this guy had gone it was
rang his wife up and he was on a cliff
and she'd accuse them of
um
sexually abusing the children
and he said I just can't
I just can't live of it he said I cannot
do it
and
he said I'm
wrong you to say goodbye
and he just yeah and he was videoing it
and over he went
and um
pretty green
another guy up in Scotland
uh
I was back to his dad quite a bit
actually and uh
great guy we took his case to the
Scottish Parliament uh he he he hung
himself inside his van
because the mother was just stopping him
seeing his two kids and
nobody thinks about the mental health
impact on fathers who are going through
the Family Justice System there's no
there's no compassion
pearls nothing there's no
how are you how are you doing what can
we do to try and make this better courts
are for criminals
you're not parents it's like legalized
cage fighting it's an adversarial system
you know to prove the best parent have
to prove the worst part is it's
good place nobody should be anywhere
near them you know there was a better
way of doing this you know and I say to
people I campaign for is
share care presumption and share care
I think with ends overnight 89 of cases
if you don't believe me let's
try let's run a pilot scheme let's give
it a go let's see if we can get better
outcomes from our children better
outcomes for my family better outcomes
our country reduce the burden on the
taxpayer in terms of legal able reduce
the burden of taxpayer in terms of
sending kids off to uh child care costs
why can't we plug in the paternal family
why can't we plug in you know the
grandfathers grandmothers why is this so
difficult do you think that
women should be held legally responsible
if a man commits suicide and it was come
to find out that she was lying
I think there's got to be consequences
to your actions there has to be a
consequence otherwise I don't know how
you could say that's not her fault
there's got to be some form of
um accountability got to be what that
how that manifests itself I don't know
but see if you have a mother that breaks
a cool order
sending a jail
send it down I'll tell you what you
start doing that nobody's gonna be
breaking cordless nobody will break
orders
but we don't do it and then people say
to me a famous whinge oh you're evil
you're an evil man you want to send um
you know women to jail
well it's not it's not a difficult
concept why should there be a two-tier
justice system why should we have a
gender apartheid
where women are treated differently to
men I don't get it and we already sent
mothers to jail
if they don't send a little Johnny to
school
they'll either get a fine or to be sent
to prison
but if they don't send Little Johnny to
see Dad
let me give us a
double standards double standards double
standards in fact
if this country doesn't have double
standards it'd have no standards at all
that's reality
all these examples
parlor on top of the other to create
this kind of it's an inescapable I mean
some people deny it like the Guardian
newspaper wankers
um
yeah they've oh that's so many hatchets
with the guardian you know kind of
really they're nasty unpleasant disdain
for for what I do and you're kind of
going I'm just trying to create better
outcomes here which I think would
actually benefit everybody why not
feminists want equality because not like
feminists say they want equality so why
would they why would they be against the
50 50 custody oh well you'd have to ask
the feminist uh go and speak to Sonia
soldier at the guardian I'm trying to go
on speak to Sonia soda she's the editor
of the Guardian what's her name Sonia
soda soda okay
you think she'd come on Oscar okay she
blocked me challenging her she wrote an
article about me
um and as I was talking about parental
alienation which is a which is an issue
about a native Behavior where children
have been turned against their fathers
and the guardian ran a hatchet piece uh
so I wanted to write to reply I was
denied a right to reply
again nobody wants to hear the other
side of of the story let's put this on
your soda who is the other she looks
like my sister
um I'll tell you later who it is um but
there's there were a lot of people
around who just take this kind of and
it's not based on fact
yeah I'll give you empirical data to the
chaos come out I can give you the
metrics I can tell you what the reality
is right if you need anything from
resources that I'll give it to you these
people there's nothing about that it's
just ideology ideology ideology this is
the low flying pointy hat broomstick
Brigade as I call them right they are
fanatical feminists the fanatical
feminist Taliban you know and it is like
a Taliban you know it's like it's crazy
we send these guys off to fire walls in
foreign countries
and yet we don't even afford an invite
to be a father
go figure why do you think Society
doesn't appreciate fathers or men I
think Society does
I really think our support right with
the third highest supported campaign
group in the UK so there's Greenpeace
amnesty and us maybe I'll say the
government the government doesn't for
the political reasons I've said they
will nudge I'll tell you I'll give you a
great quote Ian Duncan Smith right
former leader of the Tory party he's
he's very high up in the Tory Park I had
a meeting with him a few years ago and
he says if anybody goes near this issue
it is political suicide
political suicide and that's what a
former leader of authority party said
to go near this issue that tells you
everything you need to know
right people don't want to go near it
and they'll never forgive us by the way
yeah and they'll never forgive us
because we powered a bond
the Prime Minister Tony Blair in a House
of Commons in 2004. you powder bombed
her what does that mean we we smuggled
free condoms in full of
self-azing Flair
Color Purple
why and we we're here we um they just
spent half million pounds on a security
screen unfortunately for them we were
sitting in front of the security screen
and we hit Tony Blair
and the shoulder blades during prime
minister's questions
and there was up for apple and I don't
think
that and putting Batman A Buck in a
palace I think those are two things
they're not gonna I'm pulling one and
buckets Batman or Buckingham Palace
which we did later that same year so I
think those are two things why why would
you do the powder like what did you hope
to accomplish well actually do you know
what it's interesting question
interesting question
that
yeah I my namesake it was a focus
O'Connor who was the leader of the
chartist movement to the early Trade
union movement this country no wait wait
say that again my name's sake Fergus
O'Connor was a leader of the chartist
movement okay which is the full one of
the Trade union movement so we are
descended from you know whiskey tasters
Bob people and troublemakers basically
in the west of Ireland but my campaign
Spirit was I was in the NCAA part-time
movement I was in amsterdy international
before it became BC
um summer protest I was on minus picket
lines when I was a kid so I'm a kind of
um I'm an agitator I'm a provocateur I
go out and start and fight them so but
for me the idea of powder bombing the
Prime Minister Commons was a symbol it's
purple which is the international color
for quality but also it was inspired by
a stunt little-known stunts performed by
the feminists
I'm a great believer in stealing ideas
right okay still a bit of purple from
the suffragettes
we're like the suffragens really that's
what we are we're kind of like a male
version
and so I'm inspired by those kind of but
why not steal steal some ideas there's
nothing wrong with that and so the the
feminist powder bombed
Bob Hope oh it's a 1970 Miss World
competition at the war Lab at all and
they threw a flower at him
were you self-rising flour get MPS off
their backside hit Tony Blair we use the
condom to be used on every conceivable
occasion
and then sat back and then watched the
publicity
yeah and we won the front pages
I feel like did you feel like that was
like a not good
oh yeah absolutely okay yeah yeah
somebody at Downing Street said you're
the worst campaign group we've ever
heard of I said but you have heard of us
so take it
powder bomb okay you've got to be
resourceful here Paul you know so
okay Duncan Smith
so you go to court
and then he's not
once you how long does the court case
usually take let's say 12 months on
average
wow so it takes them three to six months
to get to court can take three to six
months to get to court generally it will
last 12 months but it can last a lot
longer can last years so if if he has a
newborn and the mother decides nope got
my kid you're out yep
he he might not see the kid tell the
kids too yeah
and he he really has no rights and she
has no consequences for this she can
hear what she wants yeah
so you said why do we still chain women
to their kitchens and children by
insisting they are the primary carers
what else I want to sign about
um well I was in Barbados about Rihanna
so there you've got uh
um Bayesian
woman who's pursued a career become
incredibly successful
why would you want a chainer this
presumption that the child should always
live with the mother why do you want to
chain her to the scene why would you
want to chain her to her children why
wouldn't you embrace the idea
of having share care where you can go
off and spend pursue your career pursue
a business become a YouTuber it's always
amazing things right but why not why the
would you want to have
your kids are my property it's nice I
think some of that is again down to the
cash incentivizer system that if they're
the kids the whole time they get more
child support they get divorced they get
more money because their need is great
and their fathers so the system problem
is the system incentivizes mothers how
can you go through all the incentives
that women have to take away
um the kids from the father well number
one it's about allegations you get free
legal aid that's the first thing okay so
if you reduce the amount of time number
nine is the child spends with the father
you get more child support okay free if
you're getting divorced and the kids
live with you your need is greater than
the fathers therefore you're going to
get a lie and share so rather than 50 50
you might get 60 40 or 70 30 splitting
80 20.
everything is right and also if you're
married you'll get spousal support even
after spouse or support
and like I say to men
and I'll repeat it now do not get
married
it's a trap it's a deadly trap right the
fraud of the Rings as I call it is the
worst contract you will ever sign you
want to sign a contract get a
Netflix contract right 10 quid a month
and you can get out of it outside of
marriage contract you can't literally
get out of it you can do
you know they've introduced no thought
divorce and what that doesn't they say
oh it's going to solve the problem
because it's not it's displacing the
problem from the divorce court into the
uh family call doesn't remove a problem
uh the problem remains because there's
still the divorce court and family
quarter definitely yeah oh okay and
divorce court was that a there's a trial
or is it still a judge in divorce court
uh um well it's generally a judge in
divorcing family it can be magistrates
it can be what's called a recorder or
it's a district what do you say um I've
had a couple lawyers that say you can
get a prenup and you'll be okay there's
an episode is a prenup in the UK you
guys don't have any prenups here no no
not legally binding no you can have you
can call it prenup but it's not really
fine
really yep
so the pre-nut thing is not an
established point of law the presumption
of the divorce courts in this country is
that again that they are prejudiced like
one in six
um back to one in six cases in in London
of all foreign Nationals are coming to
get divorced so bridezilla is a come
here to get divorced because the payouts
are so generous uh and there's no
Nationals yes people come here to get
people's literally specifically get
divorced in the UK because the divorce
payouts are far more beneficial wow than
they are in Europe there is a general
presumption of divorce equality in
Sweden you can't get spousal maintenance
it doesn't exist it's like stand your
own two feet quite right I mean
why
in the 21st century of men still having
to pay for women you know why are we
still having pains spouses but I said to
a guy the other day you won't give a
spousal support borrow a bike to go and
get a job if we and if you wanted to get
a quicker get electric buy it
you'll get to the interview quicker that
spousal support all right and
that's all it should be
so
everywhere you turn I mean there is no
this sounds worse than the US from
whatever the US varies from state to
state so I think Kentucky there's a
presumption of relatively new share care
and I think there's some more
Progressive there are some more
Progressive states there that do deal
with these things better
but I wouldn't say there's a pan of say
there's a lot of demand for us to go to
the US
um so I wouldn't say it's a it's a done
deal over there how oh no
this just sounds because I think
prenup's working at least a good amount
yeah
and like I think they're legally by I'm
gonna interview more lawyers on this uh
that's that's not me um how how common
is this because a pushback that I get
when I do talk about men's issues is one
I shouldn't be speaking on them because
I'm a woman
um you're perfectly qualified you've got
a father isn't it you've got a father
yeah yeah yeah well there you go right
right one man the bit last bit it says
man yeah you had a father you may have a
brother guess what you're
qualified yeah and then the second thing
is that you know um I have no life
experience I'm being
um and I'm just over exaggerating the
problem
um so I'm just curious how how common is
this would you say out of every 10 guys
that gets married how or no send this to
a child the vast majority of marriage is
going to fail right she's like 50 a lot
of the Millennials and people have the
marriage is dropping off because men are
realizing it's a really bad idea it's a
terrible deal nobody with a brain is
going to get married really you're far
better off
um we're made I'm married because just
the consequences of losing yeah kids you
lose your kids being unmarried but you
lose your financial assets and all the
rest of it that's the problem with
marriage so don't get married
um but most I say a lot of people
marriage is declining
um people are getting wise to the issues
and and problems to say it's not a
problem where over half of all marriages
ended divorce right to say it's not a
problem when it's three million kids and
fuckless homes to say is not a
problem no matter full 34 of couples in
our separate end up in the family calls
for 44. that's going to be my question
44 how many calls of couple separated
ended up in family court so if you get
if you get separated then you're like
half the time you're going to go to
court yeah and the underlying Dynamics
allows so five to ten percent a year the
cases are increasing increasing this is
an Unstoppable Trend it's a social Trend
and then you only have a 10 chance of
getting your kids
I mean most guys don't I mean despite
our best Endeavors most days that we
also have Addies and nobody speak to us
they go oh my God you know because a lot
of times like oh I'll talk to people and
they'll just say you guys are just
harping on the issues um like I spoke to
one guy
um
who he really was just a cute like he he
really passionately just felt like we
were just never talking about Solutions
we're only talking about the problems
um but
I mean how this is horrible I'm like the
more I learn about this I don't know
what positive you could come out of this
go on um do I have any positives apart
from the success stories that we get
which thank God are the 70 to 80 for you
guys I've got a really good team there
I've got the best team in the country
I've got uh I've got Nadine who's who's
our kind of lead case worker she's
amazing I mean absolutely amazing
um she's tough I call her lady balls is
her nickname
um but she's tough and we've got another
guy Dr Palin who's our kind of legal
Yoda I guess
um he's completely opposite to me
um and he's our he's our brain cell and
his knowledge of law is encyclopedic and
his ability to take on case we've won
judicial reviews we've got his case in
the high court at the moment uh he's got
a forensic ability to um you know to
disembowel cases and violent legal
points of argument so we've got a really
good team so we're lucky in that with
space what do you say the guys that say
oh just find the rate girl it's the
girls that you pick it's the woman you
pick don't speak to me I but a terrible
track record of picking women's Army
don't ask me I'll say to my sons I can
tell you how not to do it I can't tell
you how to do it I would be the worst
person in fact my sons want to set up a
vetting committee for me uh Pearl
because I'm not to be trusted out on my
own I'm a liability apparently so uh but
what do you say to people that say it's
it's just you guys just don't pick the
right women
um that's that's why this problem like
well we're going to push marriage
because it's you guys you're just not
picking the right women well listen I I
this affects everybody right it's like a
few people I said we we've we've we've
dealt with like Indian billionaire on
the books famous rock star
uh MPS Chief constables Royal protection
officers
um then you've got teachers
um you know you've got electricians
you've got I had the Sky guy the
other day ended up kind of saw mascara
ended up having to give him advice the
ocado delivery guy you know the dpd guy
coming out you know and oh you you know
and you end up everywhere everywhere I
go
I'm getting accosted by people so I
don't buy this as some kind of little
minority issue and if you think it's not
going to happen to you I promise you the
chances are statistically it will sooner
or later it will happen to you there's a
very very high probability given all the
other stats it could happen why do you
why do you say it's a high probability
when it's 50 50.
isn't that well it's not 50 50 is it I'm
saying relationship well if your
relationship breaks down okay there's a
chance you're going to end up in the
family court so that's like maybe maybe
50 50 but you don't need to be in the
course I've seen people go to court I
talk about relationship breakdown apart
from that is endemic
I don't blame them it's all too much
that heartache can can fathers sign off
on their rates if they wanted to and not
be liable for anything the state will
treat you as a cash point
and it doesn't matter how much mother
the money uh money the mother earns it's
not taken into account she could be with
millionaire she could be a millionaire
doesn't matter your liability your child
support liability is determined while
the child support agency who are Rufus
who've got crazy judicial pairs if you
don't pay what they say you owe you can
use your license you can use your
passport they can damage your credit
rating
etc etc they've got quasi judicial
powers so they are a again a starsy-like
organization with terrifying power are
there any solutions to this because it
sounds like it it seems impossible to
change the law because why would a
politician in their right mind
take on this issue when they're gonna
not they're not gonna get elected
they're going to lose vote like I'm just
trying to think how would you even go
about changing it if you can't you can't
win the election we need a new I mean
and it goes on to another vote
sorry nothing
but we but but but we need a new form of
politics so a politics that actually
Embraces men and women Okay so
interesting I think Trump delivers
yeah when he won he targeted work in
white column main to an extent and I
think there's a huge demographic who
feel disenfranchised for my political
process who don't feel they're
represented
yeah if somebody came along with a
really smart political idea
you know I think there's a market a
particular current age and a current
political crisis we live in on a
Perpetual basis in a political
corruption and whoever wins we lose
basically on every front being a
pandemic be it during you know the
financial crash but whatever it is yeah
I wouldn't let these people run a bar
for another country you know so
if you were if you were going to try to
change the law like I'm just fine you'll
be done politically it's got to be
political it's got to be political the
only way you're going to do it
but the issue is it's going to be hard
to get single mothers to vote for that
and all they're all catering you know
well I have a great faith in the British
public that there is a significant
number
of mothers who actually
will support exactly what we're saying
and I think the vast majority of the
people I think are are support in polls
I think um
you gov did a poll and we did a poll
with conrades a couple of years ago in
2019 we had like 80 public support
wow wow so the public support was it and
also we also campaigned for a minister
for men so we can coordinate his issues
we can all day a response to the Public
Health crisis surrounding male suicide
you know things like depression anxiety
we run a campaign go to SOS man down
which was like peeling back the Cosmetic
veneer and looking at how toxic
masculinity has become not these men are
toxic but if you look at beneath love
Island and you leave it but you've
always kind of there's this kind of
really diseased
you know broken uh masculinity which I
think which is why Andrew Tate has
resonated with kids and with men because
he's the kind of like an antidote I
don't think he's a right antidote with
an antidote to feminism everyone's at
school being told boys have been told
you a risk to women you're evil you're
dangerous we're stereotyping you're
demonizing you we're dead but we label
your fathers as Deadbeats
that's a reaction that's just a reaction
that people may want to reclaim their
masculinity how are boys discriminated
against in the school system well the
school system well let's just look at
the outcomes for boys I mean their their
educational records exam records their
failure rates are far more significant
than girls girls do infinitely better at
school but also when you're demonizing
boys intelligent across the road if you
see a girl coming out of the way when
you're saying that your potential
problem that your language can be
abusive and that somehow should have
been spite of these nice girls can do no
wrong and yet I know at my son's school
they were doing drugs they were
squeezing the boy's backside they were
sending their girls work yeah sending
sexually inappropriate content this idea
that women don't do that
laughable oh I mean you only need to go
yeah oh you don't gotta yeah oh I know
you see if you're getting a High Street
and I say United and see the women come
falling out of clubs if you go to a
strip show you go to Hippodrome and
Leicester Square now
where the staff men's staff are groped
by women and the management do nothing
about it
wow facts
that's something we might be doing
something on by the way in the future
but that's a fact so it's one law it
says it's like a gender apartheid
wonderful women
one or for men one more for women one
more for me
can you get
actually could
is there any way to like record this
stuff in the schools at all
I could send you stuff on it yeah that'd
be great I could send you a stuff to my
son's school I mean you can imagine how
I felt about my son being told to cross
the road of assembly I was in Camp
better I mean I was strapped at
the school yeah well and at what percent
of teacher teachers mostly women too
like there's not really the vast
majority of teachers are women yeah
it's very high very high percentage so
again there's no male role models or or
thing for boys so I think boys
particularly are I mean they're having a
really bad time of it it's just because
everywhere you look everything is
against you it's all about girls or
women it's all violence against girls
yeah women's here yeah you're gonna go
over here in a minute the vast majority
of victims of the violence amen
it's like somehow boys aren't victims of
violent what the are you talking
about what do you say when they say well
aren't men's the one perpetrating it
well yeah you look at the stats I said
the British crime service between 19.
one in three domestic abuse victims I
mean
so that's women on on men women on men I
heard
um when I watched the Cassie Jade
documentary they said good girl they
said um one-sided abuse is actually it's
more likely that the women are hitting
the men I can't find the study anywhere
though but I don't know if you like an
email yeah yeah I don't know it it
varies but we rely on a status for for
this country there's not a huge amount
of data and purple data to tap into
which I think is kind of quite
deliberate um but the data we can tap
into
we know that male domestic abuse victims
simply don't report because of the
stigma attached to I mean I know I I've
had some issues in my life in order to
go into that but
um I've certainly not reported anything
that happened to me and and and and and
almost certainly should have done but
the idea
I mean in fact I think the only time
it's time I've really been attacked
in my life
so me too actually yeah every time I've
never been threatened by a man I've been
certainly been threatened by women what
what advice would you have so if you're
gonna give
a guy advice
um first to avoid any issues in the to
begin with and second to
get his kit get access to his kids like
what would you tell them to do
well I think the first thing you've got
to be really careful because you've got
to be careful in any relationship
conception by deception so you know
conception by deception yeah rather
getting pregnant without yeah on one
appeal or whatever and then she's so
lying about being on birth control yeah
yeah that's an issue clearly that would
ever be done for paternity Falls yet in
this country because it's fraught again
should be a consequence
um I think you just got to be extremely
careful I mean the only thing I can say
it's a bit was one don't get married
because that's just insane I said if you
want to sign a contract get a Netflix
contract and get out of I mean I think
about marriage discovered recently is is
they can still make even if you've
settled the mother or the ex-wire can
still make a claim on your estate even
when you're dead
in the grave you still can't escape so
that's the first thing they get married
secondly is approach with Extreme
Caution I'm sad to say well we all get
consumed by a love and thousands of
years of conditioning about 18 and sex
and you know and I think we've got to
wean ourselves of our dependency on
women now I'm the same right I'm I'm
I feel like I'm kind of like a bit like
a like an addict but I feel like I'm
dependent but I need a woman
and I think that's quite a I don't know
where conditions I'm not sure it's
entirely healthy
I think we need to be able to say look
okay I'm not going to do that and me
personally I'll be honest with you
in fact my ex-wife is not even my idea
but it's a great idea is you know if you
want to have sex
okay
he's a sex worker I use a prostitute use
somebody if that you know because let's
face it you're not going to take your
house not gonna take your kids
and whatever it costs you is going to be
way less in the short term than what it
is going long term if you if you lose
everything
and the worst comes to the worst as I
joke it and I see the joke I'm trying to
say to the kids
get a sex bot and uh you know
you could use one of those if the worst
comes to the worst but in all
seriousness you've just got to be bloody
careful because so many people
so many people I speak to
have lost everything I mean their lives
are like ground zero and that is the
that's the tragedy here is that he's a
good
man who have done their best
who have sought to provide for the
family sought to protect their children
and acted an absolute good faith and
then have literally been
moanedown and have left with nothing
and and that is the I mean I always left
that I mean when I went through my
divorce in 20 20 20 20 not 2020 2000.
does this the same ex-wife yeah so yeah
I don't know it's different so okay okay
um
yeah well just just ironically just she
it works yeah which is a bizarre thing
yeah but okay so what were you saying um
but
why was I going with that over there
first first thing I'd have completely
forgotten I lost my life trying to fall
sorry sorry
I know I was asking like what you would
do you said a sex bot to if to to keep
to protect what should men do to protect
your asses protect your wealth
um if you're gonna have a child with
somebody you've got to take we've got a
lot of Smart Guys contact us but the
children haven't been born they say but
she said you know she stopped contact
with me I don't know what's going to
happen and that's smart if you get ahead
of the curve and you can make an
application of Court literally as soon
as the child's born
um you can deal with those situations
quite effectively
um but you've got to approach your
Extreme Caution read up on our website
read up about knowledge is power because
what you don't want to do is just
stumble blindly into a situation where
you know your entire life can be
destroyed which is effectively what's
what happens I say my life as was say
with my first divorce I was left in a
little in a bed set
with 15 quid in my pocket
and that was it
that was it my life was Ground Zero I
had nothing
and I was bailed out by a friend of mine
who gave me his camper van
10 grand
cash
and I got back up on my own feet
quickly luckily because I my
design company and stuff
I mean I was that close to it I was in a
terrible State I was
drinking too much I was depressed I was
you know hitting sir jacket Daniels was
my spiritual advisor
you know it was it was really I was
suicidal I was absolutely suicide do you
start we have a homeless shelter down
the street
do you think a large percentage of men
in homeless shelters are like from
divorce I'm sure yeah I mean I mean
statistically yeah majority of prison
population large number of them are a
father-separated dads homelessness
87 of homeless people at Maine doing the
stats on every empirical measurement
the fat with Adam is a disgrace but
mostly for women but no Miss event it is
a disgrace you know because all these
issues that all kind of I say there's so
many things that kind of spin up from
relationship right yeah but yeah you
know you just changed my perspective on
something because I never
had so I had a cousin who's a crackhead
okay yeah never really had a lot of
sympathy for him because he just I saw
how he operated saw how he moved right
it wasn't he was no victim of nothing
all right yeah loved him but he just
yeah so because of that experience I
have another relative that's also
homeless yeah and it's because of their
own goddamn choices and that's always
how I've like looked at it but I've
never really thought about if I was a
guy and I was accused of all this
I had my kids taken from me and there's
nothing I could do the system wasn't
support like if I went through this I
would be on crack too yeah I yeah so it
takes you know what it's it's really
difficult I mean I've had issues with
alcohol well I've been in a rehab a
couple of times I've I've
and I say to everybody you know I'm open
about it because it's important to talk
about these things
um
but the mental toll
you know is it comes at a price you know
you're only human you know you
just only so much you can absorb yeah
and and take and I'm dealing with yeah
I've still got my own residual issues
and I'm lucky I'm blessed but there's
still a bit of that in uh still scar
tissue and then I've still then you've
got everybody else's and especially if
you've heard enough other stuff going on
if she's accusing a man of being a
pedophile who's gonna want to talk to
him
your life is over nobody would want to
associate with him so and she has no
consequence so it's like of course he's
gonna but when you think of addiction
remember the addiction is symptomatic of
an underlying course and it's a mental
health course I mean my that's my view
in it it's it's if you drink too much
it's a mental health problem if you eat
too little your anorexic it's a then
I've got if you do drugs there's
generally a mental health or they are
generally related to something that's
going on up here that you are finding
difficult to process and a lot of people
find there's a lot of about
mental health these days and
Prince Harry and all that crap I'm
talking about problems about people yeah
dying I'm talking about people's lives
being destroyed I'm talking about
serious and that comes at a cost
and it affects us all differently and we
should be forgiving and understanding of
people as difficult and as unpleasant
and as un
um unsympathetic some people are but
there's often a trigger and a reason for
that you see the the issue I've always
had is like with them
I I understood their reason but their
reason was like it wasn't that's like
anything with this but like their reason
was so long ago yeah and it just kind of
got really old to hear the excuse and
everyone would just have to deal with
their problems so it was just like you
know she was homeless because she robbed
every family member she lived with yeah
so
how am I going to feel bad for you when
you're homeless because you stole from
us you still thought you know and it was
to get fuel her addiction can you tell
the people where they can find you well
uh well po thanks first of all for
having me it's been really great
challenge here
um if you wanted to find out more about
what we do it's uh uh fathers for
justice is the campaign organizations
that's father's hyphen four as number
four
hyphenjustice.org we're going to Twitter
uh fpj official uh Instagram uh likewise
YouTube uh likewise and then you can
there's plenty there's
extra content about how to deal with
issues how to do your case if you need
support from us
um then we offer our telephone
consultations and help plans and stuff
so there's a lot of support there we can
give you uh it's not always as much as
we would like because we're a small team
and our resources are yeah unfortunately
limited but we do the best we can and
we've got an amazing team as well so
well thank you so much for coming
um all right this was so informative I
learned so much today this is actually
crazy
um but guys make sure you like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for coming and like
the video we'll talk to you next time